the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
last time we discussed how people can
approach psychological issues in terms
of experiments and at least correlations
in some cases or causal studies through
experiments and we discovered that if
you think about money what happens on
average you become Celt less more
suffering to help right okay we
discovered that if you just change the
way that men and women approach each
other at a dating event you change their
internal feelings and their external
behaviors simply by who's approaching
what who's approaching from so you know
we learned all kinds of things that you
might or might not have known unless you
did the experiment and for all these
things that are our mental eyes and
often our feelings these are all
supported by our brains and so for me
personally as a neuroscientist I've
always thought that you have the brain
for the three amazing things out there
in the natural world the origins of the
universe the origin of life right the
brain allows think and feel
remember really everything that we do
comes from crunch feedback okay
so here's this device and I want to
share with you just this phrase that
people sometimes use which is that your
mind is what your brain does that your
mind is what your brain does okay
and so the readings from Oliver Sacks
today kind of remind you of that so
there are two women who have a have
seizures of various kinds and what
happens in them so once mrs. ocat eight
year old woman and what starts to happen
to her what's she she starts to hear
songs and so powerfully not just when
you have a little you know song in your
head that it's hard for her to hear
conversations right for her a
conversation like we're having now it's
as if the music stayed on really loud it
turns out she's having temporal lobe
seizures the temporal lobes are the
parts of the brain they're terribly
important for hearing so music is
something that we hear and it's and she
has a right temporal lobe infarction
she's had an injury in the right
temporal lobe music for most of us is
more dependent on right hemisphere
processes than the left so that makes it
unusual and she and how does she feel
about the whole process so so what's
generating the songs though wasn't
generating the songs that she hears yeah
her memory her brain right because in
epilepsy was happening neurons are
firing when neurons fire and organized
patterns those are memories desires
physical actions thoughts when they're
firing for no good reason like an
epilepsy because of some brain
difficulty they just start firing but
the neurons that happened to be firing
will drive certain mental processes that
they normally support in this case the
neurons that are firing away are ones
that are involved in memory for songs
and perception for songs and when they
fire it's as if you heard the song
itself because when you hear my voice or
when you hear a song you're never
hearing the song you're always hearing
what your neurons are in
the sound that comes to your ear your
mind is what your brain does in that
sense and you know very critical central
way if you had injuring that part of the
brain you can be cortically deaf and
never hear a sound even though all the
information came to your ear so without
your brain you know interpreting the
environment II wouldn't know what it is
but if your brain starts to fire on its
own that's just as good a signal as if
you heard a song itself because that is
the stuff of hearing songs so she had
and she enjoyed it actually she took
decline taking anticonvulsant
medications because she felt it was a
portal to her past right she could hear
the songs that she heard were ones that
reminded her of her life and were kind
of pleasant to heroes like being a
non-stop highlight film of her life okay
or Holly's a beauty three okay so now an
opposite response to a similar
phenomenon comes from and mrs. om in her
80s she hear songs but she also hears a
lot of ringing and hissing okay it's not
limited to the song itself she doesn't
mention any of this for how long four
years she's hearing ringing hissing
songs she knows because her mind is fine
that they're coming from nowhere but
inside her head
but she doesn't tell anybody that's a
huge burden right and and why doesn't
she tell them yeah you know if you're in
your 80s and you go around saying you
know I'm hearing things right people go
okay we're you know putting you in the
old-age home right you're out of it okay
so so you know she doesn't want to give
up her freedom and so and she gets a
short playlist just three songs and
hears them over and over and over again
you may have have the experience that
some songs you hear you know for a while
you like them more and then you get
tired of them okay if you had only three
all the time every day in a bad version
that was hissing and ringing you to get
pretty tired of the songs too that stops
by anticonvulsant medications and
medications that stops the seizure stop
the songs and so it's sort of a
beautiful story when two opposite you
know emotional responses for how your
mind is what your brain does now from
this the fact that songs are played back
as if it pulled out you know songs from
your computer or
or mute shelf somewhere you know you
might think that the brain retains these
records perfectly throughout life and
epilepsy will just sort them and we'll
come back that later on and say that
very much we don't think memory is that
way but we do remember songs that are
important for us and if our brain just
starts firing in the same place where we
store those songs we hear them just as
real as your cortex you hears it when it
hears the actual song itself okay
because that's the place where you hear
it
so this is the kind of evidence that in
at least in some sense your mind is what
your brain does and so here's this
amazing brain it's about you know two to
three pounds right but every thought and
feeling you'll ever have every physical
movement every desire every thing that
you're proud of are ashamed of that
crosses your mind will be supported by
this structure so I'm going to talk a
little bit about the neurons just a
little bit about the neurons that
compose the brain a little bit about a
quick tour for the gross organization
the brain will come back to many of
these structures as they're relevant to
different things like memory or emotion
or personality later in the course talk
a little bit about the enterprise of
trying to say which parts of our brain
support which parts of our mind miss
steps about that famous cases about that
that have turned out to have roughly the
right message and then a little bit more
it will focus on hemispheric
specialization the thing in humans where
our left hemisphere and the right
hemisphere are organized to accomplish
different things as a poor different
mental functions and the surprise from
split brain Orca Misurata me patients
that these different mental lives that
support our different parts of the brain
that they can live in isolation they
don't even know they're there one to the
other so let me rephrase this as you sit
there you have in the thought is you
might have independent parts of your
mind supported by independent parts of
your brain and at any one moment your
consciousness and I be in one part and
then it might move to another and just
like there's all these people in this
room your brain might be all these
things having their own independent
thinking lives okay they have to
interact a lot but how much might they D
be independent modules in your brain
that are doing their own thing and now
you're thinking about
music and those contr nan and that's
where your consciousness is now you're
thinking about history now you're
thinking about dinner tonight
and different parts of your brain turn
on and that's what your consciousness is
moving from one part of your brain to
the other but the other parts keep going
okay so we'll see how how plausible is
that so it took a long time for people
to decide that the the brain actually is
the stuff of the mind you know smart
philosophers like Plato said well
they're right it's the part of the body
that's closest to the heavens that's
where the gods might reside so that's a
good place to have your mind and and
that's what your brain is okay is there
a GPS approach to locating uh where the
mind might be Aristotle said wait a
minute is the warm and active heart the
heart was very impressive on post-mortem
examination of people who passed away
that houses the mind and that it cools
and there's an inert brain so the brain
was kind of a radiator that would sort
of cool stuff off to keep the heart an
optimal even now we talk about people
having a big heart right a cold heart a
warm heart we still talk about human a
personality or character in terms of
heart
Galen said that the brain was surrounded
his ventricles in the middle of the
brain at a fluid cerebrospinal fluid and
he hypothesized that the brain was the
packing material okay that protects that
fluid oh hang on to that fluid that's
all your stuff we're gonna cram a lot of
stuff around it right like the bubble
pack that comes in the boxes okay and of
course now we know it's the opposite way
around the mind is in the and the
physical the the dense part of the brain
not that and then you know ideas from
Descartes the pineal body is one of the
very few structures it's in the midline
of the brain that doesn't have a thing
on the left and a thing on the right and
so I thought maybe that's where things
get unified in the whole brain it all
comes together as a place that runs the
whole brain and that's a wrong idea but
people are trying to figure out what was
going on in modern neuroscience there's
many levels of analysis of the brain so
if you go to any neuroscience program
like department of brain and cognitive
science you'll actually see scientists
who study things like molecules and
synapses a molecular neurobiology how
neurons work how neurons form networks
little organizations of things that
solve problems at a higher level
Maps systems in the brain as a whole in
this course we mostly have to operate at
this level that's the place where it's
easy for us to relate in some ways parts
of the mind as we understand it of human
nature as we understand it and physical
parts of the brain it's very hard for us
to get that two molecules at the moment
but that's you know the lots of
neuroscience is working to connect these
things at different levels and I can't
resist talking from one second to about
the fact that we know our brains were
not designed from scratch you know you
are not humans 3.0 or 98 point oh right
everything in us in some way evolved
from other species that were similar to
us and far enough that dissimilar to us
so there's lots of speculations about
you know how it is that we balance parts
of the brain that are ancient in their
evolutionary roots that are more recent
in the revolutionary basis and what that
means about is another sense in which
were comprised of multiple society of
brain systems in between our ears so we
know the neurons are the cells in the
brain are glia support cells and neurons
that in iran and i know you all know all
this let me say a word about notes so we
sent tyler alright
pdfs of the lecture notes from the first
two lectures and the third one just
recently starting tomorrow we'll send
you the PDF of each lecture but the
latest by the night before the lecture
so you'll be able to print it out or or
look at on the computer okay but in
neurons have a soma or cell body
those are make up the gray matter when
we look at the brain they have an axon
that can be covered with myelin that
makes the white matter the dendrite is
the extensions of the neurons that have
the input to the to the neuron we know
that neurons communicate by
neurotransmitters across synapses
junctions between different parts of
neurons when you have a collection of
cell bodies people called a nucleus when
you've a collection of axons they call
it a tract it's just just vocabulary and
stuff and you know this from other
course is just reminding you about them
and then you get these unbelievably
startling kinds of numbers which are
always huge estimates but they show you
how amazing your brain is okay and how
hard it is for us to deeply understand
how the brain works I mean we understand
incredibly more than we did ten years
ago 20 years ago 30 years ago
we're incredibly far from understanding
how your brain accomplishes the amazing
things that accomplishes so it has about
a hundred billion neurons it has about a
hundred trillion synapses connections
among neurons and dendrites if you were
to lay out the very thin myelinated
axons in your brain just the big axons
that get myelin it was estimated that
you have 62,000 miles of axons okay
that's pretty good right I really want
to wear helmets when you go
skateboarding or a cigarette and about a
hundred thousand miles of dendrites in
each of you right so this is why the
brain is amazing and hard it's fantastic
in its complexity
an average neuron may have up to 15,000
connections a thousand synapses and to a
thousand neurons people there's
different ways of thinking about the
computational power of a neuron but they
estimate that these might have each one
the computational power of something
like a medium-sized computer so it's not
the best computer but you've got a
hundred billion of them okay now that's
the easy part
take one hundred billion neurons and
your computers in your head the hard
part is to get them all working together
efficiently and you're not sitting
around going you know computer 33 get up
to speed here we do you know we have to
something's wrong here right you don't
even think about them you just go about
your business the time for information
to go from neuron to neuron is pretty
slow compared to fast computers pretty
fast for biology ten milliseconds and
everybody thinks the secret of the brain
whatever it will turn out to be in many
ways is that you can run a fantastic
number of computations simultaneously
and collaboratively but we don't have a
deep understanding of how that all plays
out so here's a cartoon of this amazing
axon the cell body and the dendrites to
get inputs to it the axon that's the
output signal of a typical neuron
neurons going to have these beautiful
arborizations tree-like properties of
dendrites neurons have all kinds of
different shapes in different parts of
the brain presumably reflecting their
different missions what they have to
accomplish an incredibly complicated
cellular factory inside all of them you
know is producing different things and
this I mean this is a big overview this
is not so for you to learn a specific
and this here's an actual neuron that's
injected in the fantastic tree of
connections it makes with other neurons
to accomplish its mission here's a
cartoon of the synapse at places where
neurotransmitter is a signal from one
axon to one dendrite for example here's
an actual picture here's a package of
vesicles that control that could have
the neurotransmitters in them making a
connection or synapse onto a dendrite
and you just have a fantastic number of
these and you're sitting in you right
now an unbelievable amount of stuff is
going on releasing them cleaning them
away so they don't hang around too long
building you once they get ready to go
it's just an unbelievable story per
neuron could never mind the whole of
them so now we take a step back to the
brain as a whole here's the front of the
brain top of the brain back of the brain
I'm going to say a word about the
cerebellum which will talk very little
better than this course the cellular
organization the cerebellum is so
consistent that people estimate that
half of all the cortical neurons in the
brain are in the cerebellum and if you
see the cerebellar size as small you
know not that large it's because it's
packed so tightly and it's so consistent
in this organization that people thought
that's the first part of the brain will
crack because the organization is so
clear that you know we'll be able to
figure out what it's computing and how
it does it and it's turned out to be
about as mysterious a structure as any
okay I can't tell you the number of
debates about what people we know it's
involved in motor control but in many
other things as well the wiring diagram
knowing it what's connected to who turns
out to be only a tiny step in
understanding how a part of the brain
does what it does so here's this
mysterious cerebellum and then you know
here's the basal ganglia that we know is
involved in movement Parkinson's disease
affected Huntington's disease affects it
it's also involved in learning habits of
all kind it's also involved in the
reward systems of the brain what do we
found delightful and important what do
we want to do because the reward system
is turned on we'll come back to that
later on and then the limbic system the
part of the brain that's involved in
emotion and memory niggle and
hippocampus we'll come back to that if
you don't have this structure intact you
can't form new memories ever again we'll
talk
out-patients like that and then we'll
come to the smarts of the brain the
cerebral cortex four lobes frontal
parietal occipital and temporal you have
one four on the left and four on the
right these lobes are comprised of gyri
that's the part of the brain that sticks
out and then there's a sort of
indentation where it dives deep into a
sulcus comes back up it's the next gyrus
dives deep into the next office a huge
sulcus is called a fissure here's a
Sylvian fissure that separates the
temporal and frontal cortices and one of
the reasons that people have speculate
about why do we have a thing like that
why do we have you know these waves of a
gyrus going up and then plunging into
the depths then coming back up like this
again and plunging and you know from
from sulcus to sulcus and nobody really
knows but there's kind of a speculation
that's that's fun and possible so we
have one thing we know is that bigger
cortices are good not so much one person
to another but across species your
smarts or in your cortices a language
higher-level thought and so on so on the
whole species that has bigger core
diseases has a lot of opportunities for
thought and social development and so on
so you could imagine having babies with
heads you know this big and they'd be
really smart okay maybe but what would
be the problem what would be the big
problem think about it not from your
perspective perhaps if most of you are
you know adult sort of teenagers or
young 20s or something like that most of
you so you don't remember your birth
experience directly right all right but
who remembers your birth experience
pretty well your parents okay
all right your mother especially okay
it's it's giving birth is a pretty
painful specific challenging process
okay so if a head big this came out you
know it would be in condenser with the
birth canal that the mother can afford
it's already pretty challenging with
your head as big as it is when it comes
out okay that's a challenge at birth
it's not getting the arms and legs out
it's the head that's too big okay so now
we have a problem that the mother's
birth canal is only so big
we want as much brain and smartness in
our species in ourselves as possible so
how are we going to get a lot of
neocortex in there we're going to fold
it okay a lot of neocortex in there but
a smaller volume to get out through the
birth canal and that's thought to be why
the brain has this elaborate plunging
from sulcus to sulcus and the this sort
of involved a physical structure and if
we think about the brain we can think
about things that go into our brains
about the outer world
so when you see vision enters through
this area
but when you hear it enters here when
you touch or when you move your body
these are the motor cortical neurons so
it's either sort of major inputs a major
output that's in blue that's the areas
that are devoted to specific perception
or modalities or sensories and then we
have yarrow in yellow here they're the
areas that are sort of closely tied to
one modality but already they're
interpreting what's going on and then
you have areas in pink here that are
sort of not tied to any modality and are
devoted to what we might call abstract
thought and you can see the prefrontal
cortex the part of the cortex that's in
front of the motor cortex is a huge
swath like that we'll come back this we
think is terribly important for thinking
problem-solving and many aspects of the
you know the highest human meant a ssin
now we're a huge believer in the end
that form follows function in the brain
and if we understood the correct
relationship between form and function
we'd be very far and a neuroanatomist
may broaden made the following heroic
effort what he did is he section brains
into lots of thin slices and he followed
them through a microscope and every time
the brain tissue changed the neurons
looked different he would change the
number of the area okay so he started in
something like area one and the neurons
looked pretty similar and he's moving
moving moving and obviously they start
to look different than neurons and that
becomes you know something like area
three moving moving area four moving
moving area six so every time the
neurons looked different to his eye it
gets a new number the idea being when
the neurons look different they have a
different job to do and then
part of the brain does something
different and there's lots of debates
about the best way to do this or
different interpretations but something
like this holds true in a striking way
the cellular organization of the brain
reflects in some way what that part of
the brain is accomplishing what part of
your mind it supports and then we have
simplified color pictures of this and
we'll come back to in neuroimaging next
time but it's turned out to be have a
second life in neural imaging because
when scientists across the world want to
compare their neuroimaging results
they'll talk about well I got activation
in area 46 or I got in area 21 it's
become a nomenclature for the
organization of the human brain that
allows you to integrate all kinds of
imaging data about the human species and
here's a view from the inside of the
brain and here's a structure cord the
corpus callosum that we'll come back to
in the next few minutes okay so how much
are functions localized are distributed
how much is like us specific thing your
mind does and it's in one place in the
brain versus it's spread over a range
and this idea of how much things are
distributed or localized for mental
functions of the brain has been a source
of huge debate and I'll show you a
misstep and then I'll show you some
things where we think we have it more
correctly
okay the missed rep is the fern ology
and the most famous name and this is is
from gall sprits thymus another one and
in the 19th century that's the 1800s
this area the phrenology took hold a lot
and there's a sort of a Freudian story
if you want to call that gall which is
that apparently when he was a student he
was very viewed himself as a very
effortful and fastidious student who you
know took all the notes you're supposed
to take and work very hard for exams and
did everything he will you're supposed
to do but shock of shocks some students
did better than he did and he looked
around the classroom he said like who
are these students doing better than I
am because I'm trying as hard as I can
and some students are doing better and
he said hey you know one thing I noticed
about these students is they all seem to
have big foreheads okay all right I
don't know how accurate he was
scientifically but apparently this was a
emotionally a transformative moment for
gall and you'll see in what way this
ended up guiding his science so gall and
spurred time we're actually a
good neuroanatomist they described lots
of things about the brain that we're
correct that we're kind of unknown at
the time for example the pyramidal
tracts attracts that move from your
motor cortex say on your left to control
your right hand or on your right to
control your left hand they describe
those very well but here's where they
got kind of funny they said okay we can
describe the physical organization of
the brain but now let's say which part
of the brain does which part of the mind
and in a way that we now consider a bit
willy-nilly they began to assign
different mental processes to different
parts of the brain and the way they did
it was they said I'm going to look at
somebody let's pretend somebody you know
is very combative what they began to
know to figure was this well maybe the
part of the brain that's involved in
being combative the more combative you
are the more you have of it so if I feel
your skull above the part of the brain
that I think it goes with being
combative if you have a big rise there
if I feel your head and most of our
heads are a little bumpy okay you know
the person's really combative is going
to have a lot of bump there and then the
person who's very meek will have none
okay so you that make sense they have
these little categories as they just
thought about people and they develop
this idea that um you know they could
find where were cautious nasur
precociousness or secretiveness right
give it a big bump there okay let me
show you this picture here's a device
you would step into that would you know
pipe Springs go down and then would go
up and they would say where do you have
the high bumps and where do you have the
low bumps okay now all of this is wrong
because there's you know it's it's a
naive way and I'm not a scientific way
to do it weirdly enough look at what
they put below the eye language okay now
that's a weird place to put it and what
they saw was a soldier who had a wound
that went through his eye into his brain
and they said okay well he is he had
trouble producing language and they say
well that's where languages well that's
language is not below your eye okay but
but but evidentiary lies that the wound
went up into what something called
Broca's area we'll talk about that in a
couple minutes and so what they were
they they weren't that wrong they just
didn't think through where the end of
the injury was okay all the other ones
would completely dismiss these days but
we have to worry about naive
Eve ways in which we link the life of
the mind to the stuff of the brain and
they did a control experiment the famous
physiologist Magendie preserved with
veneration the brain of Laplace was a
big name in history of chemistry spurred
some had the natural wish to see the
brain spur time was the phrenologist to
test the science of the phrenologist
Magendie showed him instead the brain of
an imbecile spurred Syme who had already
worked up his enthusiasm admired the
brain of the imbecile as he would have
had admired that of Lafosse okay so this
is the control test I give you a brain
if somebody's not a genius in chemistry
and go oh my gosh is chemistry part of
the brain is unbelievable okay and this
is the old idea we talked about that you
you know if you have an idea you believe
in as a scientist you will always find
positive evidence for it okay everywhere
you look back to the brain and let's
talk about this part the lower part of
the orbital frontal cortex it sits right
above your eyes that sort of your eyes
would be something like here and we know
something about what that part of their
brain does from the famous case of
Phineas Gage so he was involved in
railroad construction in Vermont and
that involved exploding rocks to level
the area so they could put in train
tracks they would drill a hole put in
some fuse put in a powder and they would
use a tamping iron to push down the sand
and powder so there be a big explosion
to flatten the rock and at age 25 in
1848 he is a mind who was described as
well-balanced energetic and persistent
he wasn't the ideal employee you know
resourceful hard-working he was made a
forum and a leader he was the most
efficient and capable in the group and
on September 13th 1848 something big
happened an iron there was a
miscommunication an iron that was three
feet seven inches in length I'll show
you a picture in a moment because if
even if you've heard the story until you
see a picture that you can't grasp how
big this was compared to a human being
there was a miscommunication the
explosion went off early he was directly
over it the rod flew up went through his
head all the way through his head and
they had the power to land thirty yards
away after you know exploding up into
the air and by March of that year of the
next year he was back at work not too
long a vacation you know a recovery
period for that bigger thing going
through your head but his personality
fundamentally changed so here's his a
cast of
actual a head and a skull that's here's
where it shot up through here and out
this hole here's the actual rod compared
to that okay so if you haven't seen this
you can underestimate the amazingness of
this thing and at timed at the time he
was famous not for the reason we now
think of him he was just a Ripley's or
not but you know story Believe It or Not
story of that a human survived it at all
okay
so Antonio Damasio is sort of attempted
to reconstruct by computer you know
where this rod shot up through here and
out into 30 yards away right there that
big compared to him and the amazing
thing and described by a physician who
work with him at the time is the
equilibrium between his intellectual
facility faculties and animal propensity
seems to have destroyed he is fitful
irreverent and judging at times in the
grossest profanity little deference for
his fellows impatient of restraint
conflicting with his desires at times
per tenaciously obstinate capricious and
vacillating devising many plans of
future operations which are no sooner
arranged than they are abandoned in turn
for others appearing more feasible
exactly the opposite of who he was
before he was a responsible efficient
leader and now he's a totally
responsible person doing all kinds of
things that make no sense a child his
intellectual capacity he has the animal
passions of a strong man so he
completely changed who he was in this
regard his mind was so radically changed
that his friends and acquaintances that
he was no longer gauge so here's a
physical insult to the brain that
changes the character of a person that
changed what we would think of with the
moral judgments of when is it right to
tell the truth of having plans and being
a responsible trustworthy person
completely changed by this injury now
one interpretation is this part of the
brain is essential for making moral
judgments and have being of good
character what would be another
interpretation of why he might have
changed just common sense besides that
this part of the brain does that but we
want to not be the phrenologist okay so
the most one that you know the most part
is this part of the brain supports what
we think of as moral reasoning and
character well what else could you
imagine my
yeah yeah yeah I'll make up it you know
something like that but you know a more
psychological and different
interpretation let me try this one here
we go he was getting ready for the
future you know I'll be a foreman today
and then next week I'll be executive
vice president and I'll be associate
executive president and you know ya know
rod goes through his head and goes wait
a minute life is short he could end at
any moment why not just do what I want
to do all the time because uh you know I
the next rod could come who knows when
right alright and I had all these plans
and I was promising people things next
week that I delivered on but you know
that's the suckers life you know because
your life can end like that so you know
forget all this stuff about just enjoy
the moment that's a possible thing okay
you see movies like that where people
are told you have so long to live and
they changed you right what would you
want to convince yourself that it wasn't
something like that which is not an
unreasonable interpretation what you
would want to see at a minimum is that
if you have brain injuries other places
in the brain you don't see that and if
you have other people with brain
injuries in the same part of the brain
you see that consistently at a minimum
you want to say it's not just a big
brain injury but it's consistently a
brain injury in this part of the brain
that leads to this kind of behavior and
for at least this example that's true
other patients with similar injuries
behave similarly people with very very
big injuries elsewhere in the brain
don't behave similarly so that's there's
a lot of reason in the end for us to
believe that this part of the brain is
essential for something that we consider
almost metaphysical character has this
incredibly physical dependence and
here's relatively recently just a few
years ago they discovered a picture that
think of a kind of Phineas Gage himself
here's the rod here's the injury to his
eye his eyes as damaged okay so one more
example then we'll switch the switch
brained
Paul broke up and you know Broca's area
in the brain here's Paul Broca here's
the here's a brain of a patient named
mr. tan let me say a word about the
story so in France a number of people
observing patients with injuries had
talked about that the left side of the
brain is important for speech until then
there had not been much ideas
left and right were fundamentally
different so there's always sort of a
background before the discovery and
there's a talk in 1861 which describes a
man who lost his speech but understood
everything said to him he couldn't
produce speech he could understand
speech his intelligence is still
unimpaired his speech is gone and then
Broca heard that talk and he went back
and five days later a patient named
leborgne who had lost his speech he
could only say two things tan and he
could swear like crazy okay
and our current thought about that is
swearing that's emotional and intuitive
not the one where you think okay I'm
going to swear now to scare somebody but
the one you stub your toe in the middle
of night and you really let out a curse
we think that's guided like an animal
cry by the basal ganglia okay those
those heartfelt really emotional cursing
is not really language it's actually the
same cry an animal makes on injury okay
and uses some of the same neural
circuitry but you have a higher level of
cortical stuff the only word he could
say was tan he died in 1871 they looked
at his brain and they found this a
change in the left frontal cortex and we
now call that Broca's aphasia the
inability to speak despite the presence
of you can your mouth can move and you
can understand language pretty well
we'll come back to that so we talked
about Broca's area and then wernicki the
Broca's area is important for production
and here's the kind of damage and we'll
come back to Broca's aphasia later in
the course so this is a big hint that
something different between the right
and left hemispheres now in what
percentage of people is language
especially speech production
predominantly on the left and our best
answer for that confirmed thing called
the water test so this is a test given
to patients who are undergoing
neurosurgery for something like epilepsy
sometimes for tumors and they want to
know with you for for you personally
with great certainty which hemisphere is
the eloquent or speaking hemisphere
because they want to remove more tissue
if they're away from your language areas
and less tissue if they're near your
language areas maybe they won't even do
a certain surgery if they're too much in
the middle of your language areas
because in many cases it's so
frustrating for people to lose their
ability to speak there
that's okay that they'd rather have the
seizures for epilepsy than be unable to
speak so physicians and neurosurgeons
are very worried about that so what they
give you is they give you a test where
they put in a drug called sodium amytal
and they inject it into your femoral or
carotid artery it feeds up and the way
that the vasculature is between the two
hemispheres it mostly shuts down the
operation of one hemisphere if you're
injected in this fear martyr it'll
mostly shut down you're left in this one
it will mostly shut down you're right
and while the patient has one hemisphere
turned off and they know this because
for example let's say they shut down
this hemisphere with the injection
you're waving your arm it falls down
because your motor system can no one can
control your arm you're blind in this
field will talk about that many of the
mental processes done by this half of
the brain are shut down and then they'll
test you like crazy to see if you
couldn't talk let's say what are the
days of the week what's your name you
know name these pictures okay until the
drug wears off and then you come back
two days later or a day later and you
look at the other side and they'll know
with near certainty in you which is the
side of your brain that does the
speaking and best estimates are that
something like 90% to 99% of people
speak from your left even left-handers
mostly speak from the left hemisphere
because these are patients with epilepsy
we're not quite sure how they're
generalized to everybody we wouldn't do
this with typical people because these
kinds of tests are invasive and a bit
risky but our best estimates are that if
you're right-handed it's almost certain
you speak from your left hemisphere and
if you're left-handed about 80% of
left-handed people also speak from the
left hemisphere okay so it doesn't go by
handedness which makes handedness a bit
more of a mystery so now switch from
grey matter discussions to white matter
in the middle of your brain is something
called the corpus callosum here it's
viewed from the middle of the cut the
brain this way 200 million myelinated
fibers that connect the similar areas
from the left and the right this is what
hooks up differently the left and right
hemisphere from spot to spot here it is
connecting and this is from the side
view so it's a huge white matter area
corpus callosum and people notice it
because it was so striking but they
couldn't figure out what it does and it
kind of started to figure it
little bit in philosophical debates
would a divided brain if you cut the
brain in the middle would it read two
separate stores of mood predisposition
knowledge and memory that is if your two
halves of your brain we're divided from
one another would you be sort of two
people okay
now we're not going to do that to you
right but the fascinating thing is okay
are you two people to start with who
talk to one another sometimes across
your corpus callosum okay and William
McDougall said well the unity of
consciousness does not depend on the
unity of the nervous system and he
volunteered for Kerr Misurata me but to
cut the corpus callosum Erickson noted
in 1940 that epileptic seizures would
become generalized convulsions often in
animal models if you if the seizure
began here it would spread to the
corresponding part of the opposite side
of the brain and become a much word
seizure so they got the idea that if
they cut the corpus callosum in patients
with severe epilepsy who did not respond
to medications that maybe that would
make the seizures less severe that makes
sense because you wouldn't transmit the
seizure from the left to the right or
the right to the left but you know
people were sort of almost making jokes
about the corpus callosum because they
couldn't figure out what it does
they said the corpus callosum is hardly
connect with psychological functions at
all is for transmitting seizure activity
from one hemisphere to the other that's
kind of a neurology joke okay ah hora
Karl Lashley at Harvard to keep
hemispheres from collapsing into one
another I mean you do have to have
structure and you know to keep things
collapsing so now you need to tell you a
word for the next couple minutes for
this to make sense about how your visual
system is organized so here's the world
out there and if you're looking straight
ahead everything to the left people call
the left visual field everything to the
right people call the right visual field
and we'll look at this more next week a
little bit but weirdly your eyes are not
set up for that ways you could think
this I looks you know at this half and
this eye looks at that half the way it
set up each eye looks at both fields
okay
each eye looks at both fields and then
the neurons that leave the I get work in
eyes here in the optic chiasm said by
time they move out towards the brain
everything in the opposite half of the
world is reflected so everything that's
in the right visual field starts in your
brain in the left hemisphere everything
that's in the left
visual field starts in your brain in the
right hemisphere that make sense okay so
the first part of your smart neocortex
that knows what's out there is you're
looking at a face a word a scene
anything the right occipital cortex
notices what's on the left and the left
occipital cortex notice is on the right
things are so seamlessly integrated in
the brain that you don't ever have that
feeling right you almost never have like
we're getting bad signals on the left
ear I mean you know if you didn't have a
course like this you wouldn't know that
exists and you could wonder why on earth
is it like that is it just a torture
students and confuse them about Fields
eyes and brains right and people debate
about some evolutionary history behind
this but it's a great big mystery why we
don't organize things much more simply
and just go all the way this way quite
the opposite we have in the left
posterior areas that's where we see the
right half of the world and then things
get integrated is that okay
and keep in mind also that our left
hemisphere moves our right hand and our
right hemisphere moves our left hand so
at least that's the same story right
opposite hemisphere controlling the
seeing the opposite field controlling
the opposite hand so imagine these kinds
of patients who had the surgery that
divided the corpus callosum for a
treatment of epilepsy that let me tell
you a couple things clinically it was
pretty rarely done there weren't that
many of them it's pretty rarely done
nowadays first second the first thing
that people notice was it didn't have
much an effect on the patients it's a
fascinating story nobody noticed
anything okay
for decades because they didn't have the
right questions to ask okay so it was
these patients are not like astounding
patients I can't believe when I see them
right they seem pretty much like the
same as they were I'll show you a video
in a couple minutes of two of them okay
they're not they're not looking unusual
in most ways but when people figured out
what to ask of them they saw remarkable
things they saw two minds in one head
and here's how they saw that if they
showed them a picture let's say of a
spoon and a picture of a cup
simultaneously in the two fields they
would be up briefly and go but not as
easy for you to say I saw a spoon and I
saw a cup they would say what did you
see and the person would say
a cup and that would be it okay what do
you see a cup because the information in
the right visual field goes into the
left hemisphere that's the speaking
hemisphere so the left hemisphere says I
saw a cup
the right hemisphere saw this perfectly
well it's typically not the speaking
hemisphere so that information is locked
in the right hemisphere and it doesn't
have access to the speaking part of the
brain in the left hemisphere so each
hemisphere had its own experience and
only the left hemisphere could speak you
would integrate this information
instantly via the corpus callosum okay
or anybody else but each hemisphere only
knew what it saw and I so here's another
example which is not only that each
hemisphere only knows what it knows but
it's completely ignorant that the other
one knows anything okay
it's as if I if the two of you are
sitting next to each other okay and
don't know each other are not passing
notes or tweeting or whatever you know
it's just like you know do you know
exactly what the person next to you is
thinking well you might you know no not
necessarily right okay so that's exactly
what it is like like you're in one
person in their brain in their skull so
they would show them a square in the
left visual field and are trying on the
right visual field you would say I saw a
square I saw a triangle what do you want
here's what happens if they're asked to
say say what did you see
and then behind a board draw what you
saw okay
the board is there so so it's not
confusing them so here's what they say
what did you see I saw a triangle
because it's in a right field it goes
into their visual area in the left
hemisphere that's the speaking
hemisphere but if they're drawing with
their left hand what do they draw the
square because the right hemisphere saw
a square so the left hand is drawing it
draws a square so let's hema malini
ously that will say a triangle and the
hand behind the board will draw a square
and the patient is not bothered in the
least because each hemisphere only knows
what it knows the reason they have the
board there is if they didn't have the
board there then the left hemisphere
would see you drawing a square and you
go like why am i drawing a square I saw
a triangle and the person would be
weirded out that make sense okay all
right all right any okay so so but
here's the things the amazing thing is
to them have a lot of smarts by
themselves and they're completely
unaware of what the other hemisphere
knows again the idea is you the
hemispheres are talking all the time but
at lots of moments different parts of
your brain might be knowing different
things and we have a lot of belief for
that but this is the most striking
demonstration so here's a patient who
was asked to read you know say what he
saw and pick it up get one instruction
read what you see and pick it up with
your left hand so he sees the word ring
and the speaking hemisphere he says ring
his left hemisphere sees the word key
has enough language to read that and it
picks up the key behind the board right
and it never says I saw two things or
anything like that in most cases so let
me stop here and let's do can we do the
first video so you're going to see an
example of a patient named Vicky
who's going to be tested by Mike
Gazzaniga you're going to see two videos
with Mike Gazzaniga when he was younger
when he was older he did a lot of the
work with these split brain patients
plus Alan Alda for mash will visit Mike
Gazzaniga in the second
you
so one of the really interesting things
is split-brain patients have given us a
through a and asked in you and I have
different ways in which the right foods
for the left hemisphere are your own
minds and one of the things they seem to
care about and they're a useful so
here's one example from Jerry levy it's
a very clever experiment she would show
in the left or right visual field
something like this and then say in free
view which is these two things is more
similar and on purpose it's ambiguous
okay on purpose you could say well this
is more similar because it has a similar
shape or appearance this is more similar
because I use a spoon and a fork to eat
a piece of cake right and if this was
seen by the left hemisphere people would
pick by function if this was seen by the
right hemisphere the patients would pick
by appearance okay so if the idea is
that the left and this is the power of
having two hemispheres in parallel
figuring out what's going on one for
figuring out what's the information I
need about shape and things like that in
the world and what's the information I
need about function and because you have
two semi independent brains in you
you're constantly figuring out form and
function and then using whatever you
need to use to solve the problem in
front of you that makes sense okay so
here's another a nice one your scissors
projected into the left visual field the
right hemisphere that would pick the
spoon and the fork because the crossing
shape is resembling that in the right
visual field left hemisphere people
would pick the needle and thread because
that's functionally goes with scissors
so your mind is seeing the same thing
but in one case it's tuned in the left
hemisphere to functions and the right
hemisphere to appearance so these are
just notes for you going over what I
said so they talked about you know would
you have two different consciousnesses
in you it's hard really to tell they did
one experiment with Vicky where they
would present a nude picture in the left
visual field unexpectedly this was a
long time ago was a shocking thing and
the patient would blush and giggle when
asked to explain why you're blushing and
googling was that this area say patient
see which all she could say so doctor
you have some machine okay so you know
something funny happened in
Oh Priya she can't tell you just in the
language in the hemisphere that saw it
and so she gives this other kind of
description another kind of a favorite
one is addresses one there was one
patient who went back to work in his
father's grocery store and this could be
frustrating early on after his treatment
he would put stock things onto a shelf
with one hand and remove it with the
other you can imagine that would be a
slow a slow work day these kinds of
weird behaviors pretty much clear up
within weeks okay after that you have to
test to see the difference another one
they presented the instructions walk
across the room to the left visual field
the right hemisphere person gets up
walks across the room that person's
asked why did you walk across the room
person doesn't know why because they're
speaking hemisphere
didn't see it and they'll say something
like I was thirsty so interestingly they
fill in motivations okay they don't say
I don't know why or have a split brain
you know what do you expect right I mean
I mean they're they're being tested for
that right you know but they seem like
they want to fill in some other
explanation and I'll show you why
another example for that and social
psychologists have said because they
like this they said you know this is an
example that people are desperate
rationalize errs for ourselves we'll
come back to this is social psychology
you know you can think about whether
it's true for yourself or not that when
you know things are contradictory we
don't say Oh things are contradictory we
say well here's why okay why as we
explain our own behavior that we have to
rationalize their own behavior so here's
the example here's the picture so here's
what a split brain patient and he's
shown he's shown these pictures in the
visual field pairs of pictures and
visual fields and he supposed to pick
two of them in free vision they're
really to what he sees okay so let me
say here's the picture that he sees boom
this goes up and goes away now both
hands go and pick something related to
what the person just saw okay so this is
shown briefly it disappears this hand
let me do it let me do this right this
sent this the chicken went to this part
of the brain that controls this hand so
the claw goes to the to the rooster okay
this hemisphere saw a snow we seen
controls this hand and it goes for the
shovel so now they're going to make the
patient confront the weirdness of what
he just did okay
his hands went out each hemisphere
points to what it saw and again his
answer could be I'm in an experiment
you're constantly tricking me I know
that okay basically they know that
they're an experiment but his answer is
I saw a claw
that's the speaking hemisphere I picked
the chicken okay that's fine
left hemispheres speaking about right
now and then you have to clean out the
chicken shed with a shovel okay you
understand he sees he's creating a story
to make his behavior seem coherent all
right rather than just saying you know
you know I'm an experimental subject and
that's why you're testing me okay here's
the last thing when I show then I'm for
two minutes and let me show you a film
that touches on this psychologists are
interested in understanding also in what
way we see the forests and the trees you
know you see the bumper stickers you
know think globally act locally let's
talk about global and local or parks and
holes so the whole here is H and the
locals are s does that make sense it's a
way to operationalize an experiment
looking at the whole versus looking or
looking at the forest versus the trees
of s's okay
here as a whole as the C and the local
elements are O's and there's a painter
who did beautiful pictures you'll see
more another example but he made whole
phases are the vegetable parts okay do
you see that every part here of this
face if you look at a piece by piece is
a different vegetable okay or fruit all
right so it's a sort of play on this
thing and you'll see the movie that way
he made the whole face or the parts of
this but here's here's what split prey
patients doing I'll show you something
else in a moment they're asked
shortly after surgery to copy this it's
right in front of them all the time
there's no one field it's right in front
of all time just copy what's right in
front of you if they do it with their
left hand right hemisphere you see that
you get the forest but not the trees
here's the trees and then I don't look
that good honestly but still there's
some some why ish thing there copy this
it's right in front of you if it's a
left hand you get the forest but not the
parts if it's the right hand you get the
parts but not the forest does that make
sense
it's as if each hemisphere is one
hemisphere the left hemisphere we're
seeing the parts and the
right hemisphere we're seeing the whole
so that's awesome because you don't have
to be global or local your mind is
simultaneously figuring out the local
parts and the global parts and then you
can use whatever is the useful
information your mind because you know
you have multiple brains in you it's
sort of figuring out what it needs to do
last thing I'll show you then we'll do
one more video here are patients who
have lesions injuries after stroke okay
it's the same idea though so here's what
they have to copy it's right in front of
them just copy it exactly that's all
they have to do if the patient has
damaged on the right so he loses his
sense of of wholeness you see there's
lots of Z's that's the parts perceived
by the intact left hemisphere but the
right hemisphere is not giving very much
information about the whole the very
here's another patient with left
hemisphere damage that person fails to
appreciate the parts but gets the whole
here same thing down here a patient with
right hemisphere damage appreciates the
parts in the intact left hemisphere but
doesn't appreciate the whole in the
injured right hemisphere conversely
here's the injured left hemisphere that
patient copies the whole the right
hemisphere gets it left hemisphere is
missing the parts okay it the amazing
thing it's right in front of them
they're copying it but if your injury if
your brain is injured it no longer
appreciates that a hole exists or that a
part exists okay it's as if it wasn't
there so that's how much our mind is
what I bring to us in this regard and so
if we do the last video you'll see that
again
you
any questions on what you saw so I would
say you know neurons are unbelievable if
we can't even begin to figure out your
brain at the neuron level we're so far
from that the big message from this last
part besides hemispheric specialization
is that your brain and we'll see this
over and over again in this course is a
society of semi-independent brains doing
their own thing sharing information as
needed and the more we study the brain
me more we understand how many parts of
you where there are that are semi
independent and autonomous ok thanks
you